Google next is just around the corner
and as we count down the days to the big
event I'll be sharing some first looks
at duet AI for Google cloud in case you
missed it we announced duet AI earlier
this year at Google I O do Nai will
include an entire system of tools to
help developers build applications in
the cloud so once again let's take a
sneak peek of these new features that
we'll be talking more about at next
today we're taking a peek at llm Power
chat in the IDE this new feature will
allow you to ask questions about apis
products or whatever else you have
questions about in Google Cloud this
chat feature has context of the files in
your editor so you won't need to worry
about copy and paste and multi-turn chat
will allow you to refine the results but
you'll have to tune into next to learn
more want more sneak peeks take a look
at my other recent videos on duet Ai and
keep an eye on this channel as we count
down the days to this year's next